la juge d'instruction est en route
ahmadi c'est quoi ça c'était le seul
passeport disponible aussi rapidement ou
le prenais pour ce vol mais je voulais
dit j'attends ma fiancée
j'ai la confirmation qu'elle n'arrivera
pas tant donc je vais le prendre tout
seul il vous manque un pilote et moi un
avion si c'est pas le destin - tchèque
est en panne
savaria
qian bienveillant enfin on fait pas la
manche inquiétez pas chasser et pêcher
et cueillir va se débrouiller en
attendant les secours
quand même dingue de voir toute cette
étendue d'eau et rien avoir à boire
j'suis j'admire chez vous si votre texte
et
il manque un cracker
c'est quoi ce délire et amené monsieur
vous avez fait bon voyage a ajouté qu
est-ce qu sûr mais c'est comme un rat je
vous le dit yao lui et ses complices
aussi parce qu'il a forcément de
conflits sources aux quatre heures de
marche à pied
elle est pétillante sûr j'ai
l'impression que vous racontez d' énorme
bobard
mais j'arrive pas m'expliquer pourquoi